gervais pierre à chercheur associé à la
fée moore la fondation d'études pour le
moyen orient
bonjour à vous merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur arte france avoir d'abord je
vais vous demander de vous rappeler
pourquoi la russie commémore la victoire
de 1945 le 9 mai et non le 8 mai je
pense que vous venez déjà de l'expliquer
au début de votre reportage laisse pas
rentrer le décalage entre la signature
effectivement en france et puis la
signature ensuite à à berlin donc bien
ces 24 heures de différence qui explique
la banque le passage de de l'horaire de
minuit entre le 8 et le 9
d'un côté donc de l'horaire français de
l'autre côté de l'horaire moscovite
alors c'était bien aussi de le rappeler
pour beaucoup finalement le rôle de
l'urss dans la seconde guerre mondiale a
été minorée par les alliés occidentaux
est ce que vous partagez d'abord satrape
cet avis je ne crois pas parce que voyez
vous si on regarde effectivement
l'histoire il ya eu une demande réitérée
de la part de staline de l'ouverture d'
affront à l'ouest ouvrez un front à
l'ouest
donc c'est la grande décision de la
conférence de téhéran et donc six mois
huit mois plus tard à le débarquement a
lieu en normandie
il ne faut pas aussi oublier de
mentionner le support logistique que les
alliés de l'ouest et états unis en tête
ont apporté à l'armée rouge
je ne veux pas être iconoclaste en
disant cela mais il y à de nombreux
clichés sur les bords de le port de
vladivostok où on voit donc de d'énormes
files de camions américains donc sur le
sol russe et ne faut pas non plus
oublier que
l'armée soviétique et l'armée anglaise
ont occupé l'iran afin de permettre
l'acheminement de matériels donc à
nouveau alliés verts l'armée soviétique
donc c'est un ensemble il ya eu une
prise de la l'allemagne nazie dans un
système de passes entre effectivement le
front de l'est et le front de l'ouest et
je pense que cette querelle entre
guillemets de savoir qui a tapé le plus
fort et elle est elle intéressante est
elle pertinente
l'important ce qui effectivement à
l'allemagne nazie était vaincue mais
dans les manuels dans les manuels
scolaires
c'était pas l'impression quand même que
le rôle de l'armée rouge a été minimisé
par rapport au rôle des américains
et je crois qu'il faut être tout à fait
factuel et concret n'est ce pas la
population française a vu les forces
anglaises a vu les forces américaines a
vu les forces canadiennes a vu les
forces australiennes
bon donc c'est ce qui s'est passé en
donnant sur le sol français est lié à
l'histoire du seul français de ce que
nous avons vu dans le débarquement de
normandie et ses conséquences à savoir
la libération de la france avec la
contribution des troupes françaises
aussi de la résistance française de la
contribution des francs tireurs
partisans voyez vous donc
il s'agit d'un ensemble de forces qui
ont été conjugués pour renverser
l'occupation nazie et le régime ont
baissé en célèbre aujourd'hui sa 75ème
anniversaire
quelle différence entre les célébrations
soviétique à l'époque et celle
d'aujourd'hui en russie
alors ça c'est une question très
intéressante parce que là on a
effectivement 80 ans pratiquement
d'observation du dip de là
guère à aujourd'hui et donc ce sont des
stracom en géologie n'est ce pas qui se
sont superposées l'avant guerre la
guerre la victoire la guerre froide et
et après donc la situation que nous
avons en ce moment
aujourd'hui et donc il ya effectivement
une structuration que l'on voit à
l'ouest du continent européen
maintenant il y a l'union européenne il
ya dix-neuf pays là qui ont adopté une
monnaie commune ce qui était il ya trois
générations dans le temps long tout à
fait inconcevable n'est ce pas
n'oublions pas que le blocus de berlin a
été menée par l'armée soviétique
parce que l'allemagne de l'ouest
retrouver sa propre monnaie le deutsche
mark bon donc maintenant 19 pays à
l'ouest onu même monnaie et à avia à
l'est du continent
effectivement il ya eu cette dislocation
de l'union soviétique qui a été un
tournant substantielle très très
important dans l'histoire de notre
continent européen
et donc voilà nous sommes dans une
situation complètement nouvelle alors
vous parlez de l'union européenne
les festivités qui était prévu en russie
ont été repoussés de nombreux chefs
d'état étaient attendus dont emmanuel
macron coronavirus oblige ces festivités
elles ont lieu plus tard mais justement
est ce que les cartes sont rebattues au
niveau géopolitique aujourd'hui voulez
vous dire par le comique 19 ou par
l'atelier de 19 oui je pense que il y
aura des conséquences imprévues et
imprévisible à ce jour du comice 19 dans
l'ensemble de notre pays a donc en
russie je pense que la situation
sanitaire est difficile la situation
économique a dans le tissu global n'est
pas facile
la baisse du prix du pétrole et du gaz
et la baisse de consommation va porter
des difficultés est / ouest
du continent européen et bien nous
aurons à faire face à de grandes
difficultés économiques aussi donc il ya
un repartage des cartes et à l'extrémité
asiatique vient y aura des conséquences
à l'évidence de la position du monde
vis-à-vis de la chine
il faudra qu'il y ait un bilan un moment
ou un autre en 2021 2022 a sur cette
situation qui a impacté la planète et
sur le sens pour terminer rapidement sur
les célébrations en russie et donc ont
été repoussées avec de nombreux chefs
d'état occidentaux
eh bien il est tout à fait normal comme
il y a eu donc les retrouvailles
mondiale sur les plages de normandie à
qu'il y ait aussi des retrouvailles
mondiale sur la place rouge où au lieu
choisi par le pouvoir à moscou pour
célébrer cet événement des 75 ans est
tout à fait logique lier ce parallèle
cette symétrie entre les plages de
normandie et puis la place aux merci
beaucoup à vous à gervais terre je
rappelle que vous êtes chercheur associé
à la fée mots à la fondation d'études
pour le moyen orient merci